come sei partito scusa tu faccia giocare
in un attimo come faccio tutto ok come
se niente fosse
mamma mia sono volato strano niente
scusate che stavo facendo di settaggi
della videocamera ok quello stavo
facendo
mammamia massacriamo perfetto five ai
ripari controllare bellissima ancora non
potevo metterla in mezzo
peccato mannaggia la prego di queste
potrei esserci perfetto non stanno
facendo lui già usato però ci ha
riprovato la ripresa bello stanno
intenda panicare perché troppe azioni di
fiat
già i no che era il contrario
tira non lo so ma doc è bella è stara in
queste animazioni quando segni cioè la
cosa è ancora più belle che si schianta
con l'auto escludono lì dentro ha sì è
vero che si seppe il catanese
dell'esclusione gara è vero e proprio
boom bellissima cosa
comunque ti farai segnalate al posto a
tutte le volte che nel caso non lo stato
prende
ha disegnato quindi ero proposto un
peccato la campaza investire
ok ragazzi io posso iniziare a giocare
adesso ha fatto delle robe perché è il
mio sono pazzo non è furbo no madonna
che scaldarci incredibile ma dopo
ragazzi senza turbo fatto sta roba
pazzesco bravissimo mia solito logico è
stato che se andiamo altri due uomini e
gli abbiamo regalato tre gol ma anche
strand bagno se gli errori il pane degli
anni errori siamo noi abbiamo mangiato a
tutti
vabbè anche quello che abbiamo a casa
tutti a giochiamo un altro giorno dalle
10 secondi 98 76 coloro 5 4 3 2 1 c
proposte fuori ci prova seppur e guarda
come come non ha toccato terra questa
falla alla fine
guarda come non ha toccato terra come
fisicamente non era possibile ma è
uscito il bellissimo bellissimo che
piace e prevedibile sta roba da partire
impegnato subito tattica vediamo che
succede
ragazzi ci sta già parte bellissimo
bellissimo che partite con lo stesso
male ormai siamo una dell ici dovremmo
scrivere ai tornei sport impresa geniale
era un po meno quando vinciamo questa la
volete nel quale non lo farò fino a
farmi fare però c'è colore che ha
disputato nella parte giusta ok ok se la
crisi
matt o meno male che non avevo il turbo
per fare questa cosa l'ho fatto lo
stesso vai vai di pochi rivali vari vari
volti avevano fatto una schifezza
ok lasciamo ad approvare prendi turbo
l'ho saltato una ora c'è l'altro tutto
di fila tutti insieme e va bene va bene
non è vero
nuoto che mi saltano conta poco
l'abbiamo vista tutti quanti casi 100
ragazzi quindi due minuti quasi è
credibile da fare le cose non è uscito è
partito lui bene prima volta che
scappare quello che voglio è proprio
così ragazzi funziona metà partita per
far male poi
se tema tintin credibile ha preso il
turbo mannaia niente bene ok
vai in una teca va bene tutto io non ho
visto niente
mi fido io devo adattarmi state le direi
che va benissimo così ha controllato di
tutto perché nascondono biturbo con
paduli occhio che segnano sbagliate 2
ore fermano suonava ho sbagliato visto
nella baia di darlo un esploso è là che
casino tocca la tocca dell'abbaglio
bravo vai ancora noto e con loro perché
loro il culo ce l'ha ma dai ma tu a
raccogliere febbraio veramente se noi
potessimo avere il culo che hanno gli
altri nelle partite saremo campioni del
mondo bravo bravo bravo ancora andato
bravo bravo bravo bara con loro tutto
giusto paolo interno ok allora gli
rimbalza precisa davanti a noi palo ma
lui interno palo interno smesso di
ridere
l'altra per attenzione gestione
ovviamente no non ti può scavalcare solo
come a ritirare non si può scaricarlo
che va bene bloccato dai ragazzi dai
ragazzi da ragazzi vado io
vai vai vai
ora come gli studi non rispetta perfetta
lo sapeva lui no mamma mia
vai togliti dai maroni ok rimasta demuro
niente la torta precisa sempre hanno
amore loro sempre a favore loro tutto
tutto l'aria tutto ciò che è parato ero
convinto fosse gol di fatelo già
rassegnato anche io ho sbagliato tutto
era molto meglio pensavo mi lasciasse
vado attenzione vado ancora vado ancora
questo riguardo
no tutto sempre preciso titola rimbalzo
non è male non se non ce l'ho
che sfiga occhio che in mezzo fortissimo
e vabbè aut aut aut
am è bellissima
ok mai che spingiamo adesso sono per
natura è gol
ma cosa ma come e basta quanto dura
questa partita
basta ma come abbiamo fatto per noi ma
basta ma quanta sfida se momento che
stiamo giocando puntuale nei templi e
della sfiga che io veramente non ho
parole e basta e segniamo niente segnerà
loro la fine brown non ho turbo va bene
perché no non è entrata non era entrata
nel entra ero convinto che entrasse già
di suo
vediamo se vogliamo se siamo qui è ormai
tira staccava quali la dieta va lo
stesso a priori ma lo stesso e meritata
noi non perché rosico ma botto pali
interni scusatemi ai ragazzi
[Musica]
ma